Les actes homosexuels y sont un crime et peuvent mener à la prison.
Au Kenya, nous avons rencontré un homme à la voix douce, David Kuria.
David s'est assigné la difficile mission d'aider les pauvres
et d'améliorer son gouvernement.
Alors il a décidé d'entrer au sénat.
Il est devenu le premier candidat politique ouvertement gay du Kenya.
David voulait mener sa campagne sans nier qui il était vraiment.
Nous étions inquiètes pour lui
parce qu'il a reçu des menaces de mort.
(Vidéo) David Kuria : Ces menaces m'ont vraiment fait peur
parce que ces gens demandaient à ce que je sois tué.
Et, oui,
des gens le feraient,
pour eux, ce serait une obligation religieuse.
JC : David n'avait pas honte de lui.
Même lorsqu'il a été menacé,
il est resté lui-même.
LD : L'Argentine est un pays diamétralement différent.
En Argentine, 92 % de la population se considèrent comme catholiques.
Pourtant, l'Argentine a des lois LGBT qui sont encore plus progressistes
que celles que nous avons aux États-Unis.
En 2010, l'Argentine est devenue le premier pays d'Amérique latine
et le 10e dans le monde à adopter le mariage gay.
Là-bas, nous avons rencontré María Rachid.
María a joué un rôle-clé dans la réalisation de ces progrès.
María Rachid (espagnol) : En fait, j'ai toujours dit
que l'égalité des mariages
ne bénéficie pas qu'aux couples qui se marient.
D'autres personnes, même si elles ne se marieront peut-être jamais,
seront perçues différemment par leurs collègues,
par leur famille et par leurs voisins
grâce au message d'égalité envoyé par l'État.
Je suis très fière de mon pays,
parce que l'Argentine est aujourd'hui un modèle d'égalité.
Et, bientôt, espérons-le,
le monde entier aura les mêmes droits.
JC : Quand nous avons atteint la terre de mes ancêtres,
j'aurais voulu pouvoir montrer mes découvertes à mes parents.
Voilà qui nous y avons rencontré :
(Vidéo) Un, deux, trois : Shanghai souhaite la bienvenue aux gays !
(Rires)
Une communauté toute entière de jeunes et beaux Chinois LGBT.
Ils avaient leurs soucis, oui,
mais ils ne se laissaient pas faire.
A Shanghai, j'ai rencontré un groupe de lesbiennes locales
et j'ai pu leur raconter notre histoire dans mon mandarin maladroit.
À Taipei, lors de chaque trajet en métro,
nous avons vu au moins un couple de lesbiennes qui se tenait la main.
Nous avons appris que le plus gros événement LGBT pride
se passe à quelques pâtés de maisons de chez mes grand-parents.
Si seulement mes parents savaient.
LD : Lorsque nous avons terminé notre voyage, moins à voile qu'à vapeur,
(Rires)
nous avions parcouru 80 000 km,
enregistré 120 heures de vidéos.
Nous avions visité 15 pays
et interviewé 50 Supergays.
Ils n'étaient pas si durs à trouver, en fin de compte.
JC : Des événements terribles continuent de se passer
sur le chemin sinueux de l'égalité.
Il ne faut pas oublier les 75 pays qui criminalisent encore l'homosexualité.
Mais il y a aussi des histoires pleines d'espoir et de courage,
aux quatre coins du monde.
S'il y a une chose que nous devions retenir de ce voyage,
ce serait que l'égalité n'est pas une invention occidentale.
LD : L'un des piliers de ce mouvement égalitaire est l'élan.
L'élan créé quand plus de gens acceptent leur personne toute entière
et qui, à chaque occasion qui se présente,
tentent de changer leur partie du monde.
Et l'élan quand davantage de pays
trouvent des modèles d'égalités autour d'eux.
Lorsque le Népal a protégé les gens LGBT contre la discrimination,
l'Inde a été encore plus loin.
Lorsque l'Argentine a adopté le mariage pour tous,
l'Uruguay et le Brésil ont fait de même.
Lorsque l'Irlande a dit oui à l'égalité,
(Applaudissements)
le monde s'est arrêté pour suivre l'événement.
Lorsque notre Cour Suprême rend publique une décision
qui nous rend tous fiers.
(Applaudissements)
JC : En y regardant de plus près,
nous voyons une histoire d'amour dans nos enregistrements.
Je ne m'attendais pas à une histoire d'amour,
mais cette histoire contient plus de liberté, d'aventure et d'amour
que je n'aurais pu imaginer.
Un an après notre retour,
la Californie a accepté l'égalité des mariages.
Nous pensons que l'amour finira par être le plus fort.
(Vidéo) Par les pouvoirs qui me sont conférés,
par l'État de Californie
et par Dieu tout puissant,
je vous déclare partenaires pour la vie.
Vous pouvez vous embrasser.
(Applaudissements)